since you guys know about uh movie stuff
what is this movie that everybody keeps
talking about where the [ __ ] the
guy's spitting on the other guy the
hairy hairstyle Olivia Wilde is
something I love it already darling yeah
you haven't heard all the drama around
there's no idea what this is no
hairstyle a movie where he spits on
somebody no like apparently he spit on
Chris Pine when they're at the Venice I
guess film festival or something who
spit on Chris Pine Harry Styles why
that's what I thought you guys might
know Harry Styles the the he's in the
movie too
yeah bro we're not more famous than you
we don't we're not in that group you
guys know more about uh we don't
Hollywood than us let's stop we know
what happened okay to say I called Harry
this morning
I picked up his dress from the cleaners
and I said I'm on my way over
here
oh [ __ ] no I don't know I don't know
what happened did they get into they
have beef I don't know I find myself
Chris Pine jacked
where you get people off the street it
was so cool he was in [ __ ] Star Trek
and then he just came off the street
watched the show was a great audience
member with his girl came up to
everybody he was like yeah
no idea he wasn't going to show you were
on okay it was like a Sunday I remember
him he got yeah he got a pretty mouth
[Laughter]
he spit on him that's the rumor that
doesn't spit on him when super famous
people come to your shows do you get
nervous or weird or no you're cool more
nervous like if my family's there oh
right that's the [ __ ] friends or
somebody does yeah yeah hands down yeah
whenever somebody's I do love playing
Chicago I'm like I mean yes but also my
family's it's the most nervous just a
different world yeah you're thinking
about them yeah and also how many of
them are like Hey What Can where's the
thing after the thing yeah I don't know
I've got to focus on a show I'm not
going to the thing yeah it's a nightmare
well dude you know what the great thing
is not like when I did Chicago Theater
you rent out the basement yeah that's
right just go downstairs yeah yeah then
I can see everyone say hi and it
appeases them and then you're done you
know what I mean or the stress of like
you you put somebody on the list and
it's like you're about to go up and they
call them we have six more people yeah
yeah we're sold out but can you you know
you have to deal with other [ __ ]
stress I get why Fighters don't like
fighting at home yeah you know what I
mean like I get why they go to Vegas
obviously there's more money to gambling
but like fighting at home
it's just non-stop phone calls and [ __ ]
and with fighting instead of stand-up
but you really gotta prepare your life
two months yeah 100 with stand up you've
been preparing for a year as long as
you've been on tour also we're not going
to get CTE yeah yeah our ego is on the
line their life is on the line right
that's very good yeah that's that's that
is very good that's like the [ __ ]
tagline for the film his ego's on the
line
his life is on the line stand up versus
boxing no but that [ __ ] that playing
at home is tough tough tough I just
don't it's my one of my least favorite
things yeah until it's over and you're
like oh it was awesome I did it they got
to see it but it's different for you
because New York you guys New York it's
just yeah that's a different thing
almost Dallas for me but yeah I was
curious because you're you're probably
more used to family coming just because
you're at the cellar and it's just
friends and family can swing drop in
whenever yeah if I go to Dallas it's
like that's the one time that year yeah
yeah that makes sense yeah
um guys I know that you guys have
another podcast that you have to do very
soon did you have fun on this one I mean
you got some we have we still have time
we still have plenty of time yes yeah we
got to have one we got some more times
right now 3 30. I'd like to go okay so
maybe we have another like 15 minutes or
something I think we have some more fun
okay what are you gonna do for like
those games that you guys play or
whatever yeah
no no you're like oh look at this video
let me ask you let me ask you something
as a friend as a friend yeah yeah is has
this been one of the best versions of
this show oh yeah amazing without it
yeah get amazing yeah you had to come
back yes yes I mean you go I'm coming
back how many times
well I've been asking you for [ __ ]
years [ __ ] you never come here when
he says this yeah
I swear to god dude just give him a kiss
it's all good this is aggressive too
this is aggressive oh dude you guys met
each other in France
[Music]
this is aggressive too Bobby [ __ ] you
man see what I mean yeah okay all right
sexual tension this guy any part of
Europe he's bonjourno
anywhere he goes well what are you
saying tally is no yeah you put on
[ __ ] French music
French
oh you're saying bonjour and then no
guys guys
in Italy what do you say yeah you say
you say we we there it is I love it I
love it all German what's German you
know what they say
I don't know I don't know you can't do
those things
yeah Mommy I was curious what happened
to the guy that uh that diddled you
whatever happened to him I don't know
because it was in Minnesota and we moved
when I was 10. he owns Amazon
no
it's beneath me if you're out there
listen
I think you were beneath him buddy
listen yeah yeah I think it's awesome
that you um you were able to get
something out of it what do you mean no
just like you turned it into a positive
positive well it's you know here's a
serious note yeah but my therapist
always says that because you had so much
trauma in your life yeah that you had
you developed like this weird sense of
humor as a defense mechanism and then
you chose that one thing that you were
able to do guys this has been flagrant
why you think it's me
yeah thank you it's the funniest thing
to do yeah
so that's you know that's your defense
mechanism no but I look I use that as a
career and it's worked out I think if I
didn't have that or like if I lived in
Korea and there wasn't like stand-up
comedy and comedy in general can we go
to Korea I would love to do can we do a
trip I would actually I love that just
to have fun
yeah we could do karaoke together yes I
do not want to go I would love to go
dude that's mine I'm being [ __ ] real
dude I'm being real too I just have to
be very sure about Santino we need to
it's my least favorite Asian place
what's your favorite day yeah Japan
Japan's the best
number one Korea is now Korea dude Korea
is the number one they got heart they
got emotions let me think about it yeah
yeah
yeah no it's Japan I don't know
of course I would go I just need to be
sure about the meat that we eat what
what oh the doggy yeah yeah yeah
vegetarian you know yeah go get his dog
dog meat yeah and bulgogi is cow cow big
dog big dog
yeah dog but we don't have to eat that I
would never eat dog okay you would never
I have dogs yeah they're in my freezer
I'm gonna even litter
hey
no I would never eat I love my dog so
[ __ ] I would never eat them no
there's no way survival I'd rather eat
my horizons survival if you need it yeah
my cousin Andy died I'd be sad I would
eat them instead of my good dog Gobi you
know what I mean yeah yeah yeah what's
so funny you named your dog after the
dish
yeah you're right yeah that's weird yeah
yeah my dog cheese
and that's the one I tongue kiss all the
time really yeah that's okay why you go
Behavior what he does with his dogs is
not okay you think it's inappropriate I
believe you I do it's disgusting he has
no idea what boundaries are this guy no
like I kissed I kissed my dog on the on
the top of the nose like on the head
like I'll give it a look at yeah he'll
mouth [ __ ] his dog